Welcome everybody, to another episode
of the H3 Podcast live.
Today, our episode is sponsored by D-Brand, Seat Geek,
Naturebox, and—of course—h3h3shop.com. Today, we have the illustrious
VideoGameDunkey, and Leah. Leahbee?
Leahbeex? I don't know how specific I need to get.
Next week we are having Kripparrian,
the Twitch streamer and hardcore gamer.
Oh, I need to put up a thread so you guys can leave your questions for him. I haven't done that yet.
I don't know who to scream at to make that happen—probably just myself.
But in the meantime, before we get into that next week, we have got these two legends here. Now Dunkey,
who is—I'm looking at his back right now.
They didn't want to make it awkward—for me,
'cause I was gonna do an intro, and usually the guests walk in, but they were like, "Well, we're here already." Can you show the wide?
So they're just sitting here, and their backs are facing me. I feel like of the Blair Witch Project.
They're really committed to it too.
VideoGameDunkey.
No one makes videos like this guy. He's a one-of-a-kind masterpiece.
How did I do?
He's known for her loving spaghetti and meatballs,
and, he is also black.
Yeah, nobody knows if he likes it, but he—I think he likes it.
He's a man—he's so powerful, he was blacklisted from playing League of Legends. Forever.
Which is a badge of honor if you ask me. And probably he would agree.
Leah, his carer,
also as a channel—Leahbee—where they make vlogs and cute videos.
And now I present to you my friends, the illustrious, and the wonderful,
Jason, and Leah.
Hey guys.
Now you gotta—
You gotta turn around!
Thank you guys, it's really nice to have you here. It's so cool.
Thanks for coming.
Yes, thank you for inviting us.
Yeah, I feel like you're elusive in a way,
'cause your—your videos are so prolific?
But your character is kind of elusive, so it's really cool to have you in here and see—
I mean, I'm just a stunt double.
I'm not even the real guy.
Okay. 'Cause the real guy is black.
Yeah.
What's the deal? Why does everyone think you're black?
I am.
Oh, okay.
I think it just came out because—well—he never really did face reveals,
He would, like, put in little clips of his face, but he wouldn't say, like, "Hey, this is me."
And then people just, like, heard the voice and they were, like, "That's got to be a black guy."
You know what's funny? I thought you were black for, like, years. I was sure he was black,
I don't know why. And then I saw your dancing video that you did for, like—
you did some, like, subscriber milestone?
It, may be a million, or something?
Was it the one—it was all snowy? It was winter?
Yeah.
She helped me.
He made me walk around all—
for, like, a week! And that's—it was, like, five degrees out? Yeah.
Yeah, it looked freezing. It was very jubilant.
Very happy.
A lot of confused college kids.
Did anyone recognize you when you're shooting that? No.
They're just like 'This nutty guy...'.
Don't know why yeah, I thought you were black for the longest time, and I was like oh my god
Not black. I guess it's the voice
He's got kind of right
Got like a Louis Armstrong thing
Nothing there master
Yeah
jazzy boys good lord
Well, we've got some some wonderful things here too to celebrate today
Today is mining Ellis five-year anniversary
Thank you so much
And we were at Disneyland yesterday with these two guys
celebrating our engagement, yeah
First announcement congrats, tell me about tell me give me the details
At the post office romances began yeah, I had to ship some packages
And I came back out to the car yep, and he just said look in the glove box, and I was like why
I don't know if that's I think that's even better than putting or like more romantic possibly than
We see it you have it on yeah, can we get a shot if you like
Actually was good because it surprised me because we were coming on this big trip
so I would have guessed you'd like do it at Disney sometime, but
That would have been expected so you know it was a surprise in the car, okay, but you guys planned a vacation
Mm-hmm, but who planned it because was it because of the engagement we planned it for my birthday. Well shit was on Sunday
Oh, happy birthday
Like a double celebration yeah
Damn cold still cold heart
There was someone on Twitter actually I wanted to shout her out because she like noticed when we posted our picture yesterday at
Disney she saw that Jason's wearing the button
And she saw my ring like really tiny in the photo and she was like they got engaged
I was the only like on it. I liked it
Good job that move like get me into the
Yeah, we had like talked about you know getting engaged like sometime within the year, yeah
You had you had hope so
That's what I mean. That's what I was talking about we're a Disney. It's like look
We both knew they were gonna say yes. We don't need to get on horseback and do all this
That's for insecure guys who are like
I'm going to spend a bunch of money to put the peer pressure on them
So they can't say no because I spent $100,000 on that romantic
That's right
Love is putting it in a bag of baby wipes
I think some girls out there
Do yeah they want your like moment they want to feel like you know the most special moment, but that ain't any
With some people. It's just like a mutual. You know yeah, yeah, I guess that's fair
I like your opinion where you don't actually have to hate on people who think differently
Horses are special fucking you gotta feed them
Honey there's a there here the ring is in the is in the box, and there's also a dead horse
You may have noticed I was part of this my wedding gift. Thank you
Horse jerky
Listen I saw this tweet today
Jason and I just wanted to
Know the wicked wolf had said today's the day I finally unsubscribed from your channel, you're a complete fucking imbecile. That's a shame
It was a big
Video he's gone. He's
What was it about the new video? I didn't see anything controversial about it. Did you watch it? Yeah?
I didn't think it was controversial either it really likes those Tekken 1 cinematics
I don't know if he's out there. Just do a follow-up. What happened. Yeah, it wasn't about it. Yeah
I'd like to know more to tell me uh how was your relationship with your fans? Do you see a lot of reactions like that?
He complains a lot about like people not getting his
intention
What is kind of frustrating like which video in particular?
Well this
One, I kind of like confused when I'm trying to get it
Mm-hmm because a lot of times you do something that's kind of a parody
And then there's kind of not and kind of like there's a lot of layers to it, so I fuck maybe for some people
It's easy to like miss the point
One thing I found on YouTube is like you can't be too sore
It's hard to be subtle you have to like hit people over the head with a club
Because I think a lot of the people who write
Comments like they'll write it cuz they were like either didn't like it or they were confused
But if people were just like oh, okay. Yeah, cool, then they'll just move on they're just really great the combination. I got it like
Jimmy Collins ever get to you Oh
Never
He's so like he has a thick skin about that comment. That's good
I'm more like offended by some comments sometimes, but but you seem like you wanna get sued he's like
Why are you looking like just ignore it?
But it's such a it's so messed up because like you were saying most of them are good
See you have a healthy view of it, and my thing is like and I know it's sick, but I'll be look
I'll look at the comments, and I'm trying just not to read them anymore because it's it
But it's like I'll skim pass like all like ten of the nicest things anyone ever said about me
And then one guy was like fuck you buddy
That's kind of and I'm aware of that some eight-year-old is like getting
Funny thing for like my channel and stuff to my mom like reads every cop, Oh Mike
She's like getting deeper than me. She reads all of them and I
Don't I can't
Did she ever text and be like I saw this today, and I just wanted to tell you
One of the talks about it yeah, I don't know she's texting me, but she definitely brings it up like when I go visit
My dad
Commenting nasty stuff
Do your parents watch your videos? Uh-huh I think so do their mom we used to kill the missions where you swearing in these videos?
My kids they're gonna look it up and swear
She's a good second-grade teacher. Oh, that's yeah, so
So I want to ask you because I'm really this most people on YouTube
I watch their videos, and I understand how they're made like I understand somewhat the creative process of what's going on there and
But with you, I don't really understand how you make those videos that you do like
Do you record tons of footage and then voiceover or later, do you do voiceover while you're playing the game
You just sometimes like how does that work? It's it's always different
Sometimes I'll write a script sometimes on this record
Three minutes
Okay, so you're just when you do that
Are you looking for like a specific like shot or you're just like oh that happened, and that was funny
I'm gonna say like like a montage just like overwatch video or a league one
No, just say. I'll try to cut out the funniest parts mmm
Overwatch feels like it takes like months now to just to get four minutes of entertaining stuff one game. Yeah
Like what can I do anymore?
What does that mean what does that say about over welcome?
To the fucking ocean
Second you have massive hard drives
You have such a good system were like oh
Yeah, you gotta use fraps. Okay, okay?
every game fraps and then every time something happens you hit the button, so you know to look at the end of the
Then you're going through like 3,000 clips
You just skip to the end every time huh that's brilliant yeah, and he has to clean it out
So it's not like you know his whole computers always follow usually every day. Yeah, I
Just a bag of Cheetos on the desk
Just like Cheetos all over the
So I've always had trouble desktop recording, I don't know what's going on in my life, but I'm having multiple computers
Multiple programs, I've used like Camtasia. It sounds awful right I mean the name
So there's so many tears what am I doing wrong for like a game?
Anything recording YouTube
Well you know if you record with like bandicam and HD I
Add it with Adobe, and if you put HD shit. You can't edit it. It's like it'll take like a minute to respond
That's just it's like undoable I
Just do like fake HD like 70 yeah
Cuz you putz it all up anyway the video
As long as it says HD
En XD there you go, it's a funny idea for a video super 4k
You can come over and set it up for you at your oh, yeah
What program do you use to edit I do?
Yeah, it's a love/hate. Yeah, do you wrestle with with premiere a lot? Yeah, it's sometimes. Yeah. Yeah, shit well
That'll just what the fuck. Yeah. It just that's what the fuck happened. Yeah
Like what? I'm dealing with now is that when I make a keyframe it will just randomly twist hmm for no reason
There's a twist in it
so I'll go like at this image to go to aid to be and then it's just like i'ma go in a fucking rainbow and
Go up this green. Yeah
Between the keyframes instead of a straight line. I don't know why I'm just like what?
It's a learning curve seventy years
You get to understand the quirks often feel like in Premiere, I'm you have to like outsmart the bugs
Like a sink whant a sequence were like not work will be something wrong so ok. I need to create a new sequence
change the settings to
put that in there
Restart my computer five times, that's the solution on the official forum
So when you're editing you have all this footage
Do you just like painstakingly go through all this stuff?
Or do you have an idea afterwards you're like using that trick you said?
Or do you just watch like hours and hours of footage?
I mean I watched it so much that one of the ideas happened then but sometimes
I'll add it all the guidance a shit sucks you do it all
you scrap videos a lot ah
Really anymore. I just try to think everything out now mmm nice time
on the back burner
I got ahead enough, but I didn't so I save it for later. I see him do a lot
That's cool. Like the video you posted today about the bad graphics that apparently caused the exodus
Like you mentioned that you had been working on that for a while so tell me like about
How that video came to be I just started writing like a little script and notepad like last month mmm
I can't think thank this through. I can't get it all together, so just wait till later
And then later you find like you just think about it
You don't like a different way to sometimes like the timings off, too
Like you got to get a new video out mmm. This one will take too long
I'd be on time yeah, yeah, when a new heart like is out were you just like grind for 16 hours
Will you let the crazy?
Cuphead I'm still
Okay you have a cup head video coming yeah, so a lot of people were asking because we have a thread video
Bed no comment for now you'll have to watch
Yeah, we have to like plan our trips around like game release schedules and
Excited for that you got to stay home from reo you can't go anywhere
Take everything off the calendar
My favorite video of yours I think or one of them is the Skyrim one with just all the insane mods
colliding like tell me about the process of how you you that video came to be I
Mean, I think that was just like seeing on everywhere you're going to just see like people just posting mods Skyrim
Just like the shittiest monster the dumbest shit ever there's so many
People just I just wanted to see like how much that shit I can enable at once
Everything you can enable everything at once it seems like like a supercomputer
Like a prebuilt one
It's a predator Jason
So basically you started from just this point of like I want to throw all these in it
See what happen and it was it was
such a joyous I
freaking love that video
His first when they got to the top of Reddit. I think really really no it's kind of like a breakthrough
Like their mom stuffy. What's that cool for you? Yeah? I think that brought in some new people mm-hmm
Do you use read it? Yeah? I look down there sometimes say like comments
sometimes
Sometimes there's some smart stuff on there clever stuff and sometimes it's like worse than YouTube
Huh, yeah, it's true, I don't know when and where to look so I just stopped looking honestly. Oh, you don't like it
We try not to look yeah
Yeah, I think that 1:19 look at the comments didn't read them at all not
Because the thing is like I need to make the conscious choice because I know people like that video
So I need to decide do comments affect me or not
I can't look at them when they're good and then not look at them when they're bad
I'm gonna want to look like either way, and I don't want to look at the comments on a video
That's like mediocre because everyone's just gonna be like
Super rude and like heavy. I'm like yeah
It wasn't the best video, but you don't need to fucking like can't eat my children about it
And so for me. I'm like. I can't like pick and choose when I'm reading it needs to be all or nothing right
Yeah, it definitely can reduce your stress a lot if you decide I'm done like looking at yeah. It's I read every single
And you're not super depressed all the time I
Know it doesn't take any effort to write them income you know to see someone put an effort right now
It was really nice uplifting comments. That's really good. Dude. God bless you man
Seriously we should maybe I should do that yeah, that's actually really cool. We used to do that
YouTube is like introducing like a filter now like a censors thing
Did you see that no I think so I get blocks comments now
I feel like they're just typing then like the n-word or some shit. Do you have that on? Yeah? I think it helps
Mm-hm I mean should I hope with us. I hope it works
It's kind of like I always wonder like should I sense should I block certain comments or just leave it all open. It's like
It's like not a free speech thing it's like just I
Don't need people screaming the N word in the comments like the world was not losing anything
I don't know I used to think like that all right. I don't need a bunch to deal. Yeah. What do you delete on?
Your studies don't think oh you should never delete any all right. Thank ya
So when you delete a comment like when you decide this one it just gets me angry it's like the dumb
Especially if it's a really long one. That's like fuck you just wasted all that time
Do you block because you can mine are you banned I'm black right now spam one like hey
It's me donkey, and it has my fucking picture go on this link and it's like a virus and shit
Then there's like a comment why'd you send this to me?
Well to be fair you give him a virus I totally understand where he's coming from
What's your favorite types of videos to make
It's like something new something that doesn't like super formulaic
He just made like a movie review he like The Shining one it was great school. Thank you
I enjoyed that a lot dude, and I think you're fancy too because again one of the top question was like
Are you gonna do more movie reviews do other kinds of reviews?
necessarily before
Movie stuff on YouTube, I see like a lot of those movie YouTube channels, they get in trouble what's real that's copyright stuff
Yeah less so with video game stuff. Yeah like video games
I don't know. I feel like you can usually get away with it Nintendo will sometimes crackdown
But even then you know a lot of Nintendo stuff will still get through and make money
I was gonna ask you because I heard about this Nintendo thing they when did they do this and make this new policy
Forever ago really. I think I was like two or three years ago
What was it they just take all the like if you have a Nintendo song?
game, they'll just take all the money I
Don't know it seems self-defeating like it's not much money for Nintendo
That's like
So much promotion so little money they're trading like ten bucks
Yeah a hundred million views. I'm free promotion. Which is pretty much what you make on YouTube these days
Did you stop making like Nintendo related content as a result are you still doing your thing? No. I'm still doing it
cool
Well, let's take a quick break to thank our sponsors
And we will be back after this short, thank you to the boys
Stay tuned
and
Now a quick. Thank you to our wonderful sponsors beginning with DD brand nice
D brand is an incredible company a big fan of that
I am a big fan of and they're a big supporter of ours and creators in general. They make this product
It's like a decal that basically transforms your phone into a whole new slammin hot item
Um show the website here, you can basically customize your phone
They've got uh decals for every type of foam wood it looks so genuine
You know metal and everyone's favorite
Green eye previously had the marble
marbles great stones really cool
I mean it looks genuine and it really it does protect the phone
Without the bulk of a case if that's not what it you're into but today
I am here to talk to you about their upcoming product. Which is a phone case called grip
Look at this basically grip
Answers the question here while most competitors are doing
Well most competitors aim to one-up their competition on drop test. They're looking answer the question
How do we stop phones from dropping in the first dang place?
You know chicken or egg they say egg
The grip does exactly that gives you confidence that you're not going to drop your device
That said if you do it still got world-class impact protection technology built-in guys, okay?
I'm actually really hyped for this. I'm 100% gonna get this when it comes out if you guys want to
Sign up for the newsletter go down to the bottom, right
Put in your dang email, and you'll get notified when this hot slam and baby comes out soon
and I'm definitely gonna be hyping this when it comes out I
Got this cute little video here
It's a race car. It's driving. It's slammin. It's shifting. It's all over the track and then a whole sudden oh
My god, you will not believe what you're about to see
The phone I was on the car the whole flippin time now frankly
I don't know. You know probably not a practical use, but it it shows you how serious business this is
So guys head on over to Dee brand.com slash grip and let him know that
You're gripping that you're gripping
so thank you to D Brown for supporting the show and I'm looking forward to that new that new case and
next up I
Love these guys seeking because they don't seek keep by the way is a website that aggregates
Tickets to live events from all over the world to make buying simple now
We all know they have a great product and a great website
But what didn't we know is that? They're good ask great ask people my brother or my sister my dad have like a combined
Birthday in September their birthday very close to each other and they're both huge Dodger tickets, and I hit him up
And I'm like can you guys hook up my my dad and my sister for?
For the Dodger game coming up. It was it was Game one of the playoffs, and they're super excited
It was sold out so that can you can you do anything for me?
And look at this look at what they did for my family look at these fucking seats
dugout right behind first base
First base, I don't think about baseball, but basically this the best seats
They've ever had they were so happy and I was so thrilled that that we were able to hook him up and seek he
just Pony tup and
Good guy seat geek
Apparently it's like a whole different adventure back there. They've like free buffets. Yeah memorabilia a
Complete experience. There's apparently like
Crab claws just stacked high on ice and you disappear entirety people live there, just like Oh claw for the go. It's like go-gurt
So anyway, SeatGeek, I just wanted to give them a real big. Thank you to these guys
I was super nice to them basically how it works is they give you a
0-200 score on his ticket to let you know how good of a deal you're getting or if it's a bad one we're green equals
Good bad equals a red so you know um
You know I'm compromising this one's not as good of a deal, but I really want to see it or hey
This is a great value
In the app you can get a view from your seat
So you know where you're gonna sit you know what you're getting yourself into is it a great seat. Is it a nosebleed?
You'll find out right away
Guess what go to seat geek comm?
Link in the description
The game app and use code h3 h4 you guys you got to download the app use code
H2 h3 and get $20 off your first order click the link in description below to download the app code
H3 h3 god bless you see geek you sweet
Sweet ass Fox
And who's next some brands don't like me to curse in their spots, but
Hopefully, they don't mind I do it to highlight how much I love you goddamnit. Thank you see kook and
Lastly, we've got
naturebox who I love because it helps me cultivate Fupa I
get thick and voluptuous and beautiful, and you know what they do their best to prevent that because
Their whole thing is that they make snacks that are delicious and nutritious and don't have a billion calories
But guess what when you eat as much as me that doesn't really matter cuz it's so frickin good
You're not American unless you crack open three bags of snacks in one sitting
Nature box has over a hundred snacks that taste good and are actually better for you all snacks are made from a high-quality
simple ingredients which means no artificial colors flavors
Or sweeteners, so you can feel good about what you're eating and boy. Let me tell you I feel good
probably better than I should
Look at this their snacks are off the chain
Probiotic power mix that means it makes your butthole healthy yeah, I think or stomach
Yeah, why not say well. You know it's all. It's all tied together eula
tried mango
pineapple
Vanilla bean wafers. This is my favorite the sriracha roasted cashews those
Well take you on an adventure a whole new ride. It's like a ladder when he was on the magic carpet
That's what these cashews are for you spiritually and emotionally
Cheddar cheese crisps
Are you kidding me dark cocoa nom noms you put nom nom in the title and you expect me not to buy it
There's hundreds of these
Okay
They basically you know you're sure to find your snack obsession at naturebox
They had new snacks every month inspired by real feedback the latest food trends and professional chefs
It's simple guys go to nature box calms twos the snacks you want a nature box will deliver them right to your damn door
Your goddamn door and there's no risk you ever try snack. You don't like don't eat it because nature box will replace it for free
So check it out. Goodnight con /h Street right go right now right now?
to naturebox calm
Dance get 50% off their first order
What did I say wrong the first thing you didn't say this oh you guys wash it yes
Naturebox calm
Order man naturebox calm
We all eat snacks
This is a better place to do it folks so thank you to our sponsors to seek geek D
Brand in nature box if you're in the market for any of those
Support the show by hitting them up
And finally just a little promotion here
New shirts in the h3h3 shop calm
Because YouTube has demonetised our channel, and now this is our new source of making Adsense
selling shirts
But luckily we're on fire
This is a vintage vapenation shirt that is sure to explode your game and get you cultivate Fupa get
Get you know touch of vagina. I don't know this shirt will enable whatever it is
You dream of doing and more go to a tree shop calm and pick yourself one up today. Thank you guys for
Sitting through that and now back to video game donkey and Leah
Welcome back with the illustrious and prolific video game donkey and Leah, can you guys please join?
As we did the reads we made them face the wall so that it was less awkward
So tell me who in your opinion makes the best games, Nintendo
a lot of good indie guys
There's so many good someone hungry guys out there trying to make good shit
It's a lot of competition right and then a lot of more competitive than ever
For the Indies yeah, yeah, the games are crazy
But if you go to like the conventions like packs
Stuff like that the Indy section is always like the best part of any convention
Like more so than you know the big companies just more interesting more experimental. Yeah, we get to play the games yeah
They're like right there
That's awesome. Yeah. Do you what do you think about Nintendo as a company because I actually agree?
They make the best games, but like this shit on YouTube
It's just like so they're like what they're so out of touch right it's like
Just everything like in what way?
They still don't know how to do Internet at all like you have to do it fucking
17 digit friend code instead of just add in somebody's name
And like product launches
They never make enough yeah
It's not it's like they're selling diamonds make more switcher
Shout-out to you guys I can get a switch yeah
Sweet ass Fox. We're like. I just bought an extra one. I'll mail it to you. It's like
send me a switch I
Guess that explains why Nintendo is so like oh you can't use our games on YouTube
They're just out of touch you think that's what I think
It's like the switch, you know of course they want to make more, but they just don't I guess they don't have the
Production manufacturing
Yeah, but why not you'd think they could get as much as they want yeah high standards or something
Yeah, so what is it about them that they make the best games like do they have a philosophy or something?
I mean what is going on? They're like they just have all the most talented dudes like
It's got all Japanese dudes this they take their work so seriously
I think this is that culture it's like that honor yeah that deep ancient honour
Because it's so serious. God bless him like I remember I read a thing about Sonic 2
like they try to stay co-developed it and they had like you know they brought in Jeff and
Workers and American workers and American guys are just fuckin off goofing around
Japanese guys taking this so seriously
Track their hardest to make the best game ever you think I
Love that done' way cuz it's like you're making a video game show like oh, this is my dream
I'm a video game, but for them. They're like I will
Start by the samurai sword this is the best game of the decade got it. Yeah, maybe that's it
Let's take a call
Country boy 420. I love that name. It's like a little incestual. It's a little 420. What do you got for me?
Wait what happened we got to make sure this where do you go?
Oh country boy. Where'd you go?
I think I moved country more 422 the wrong channel. Can you help me?
Get his ass in there. Thank you boy for 20
Community such as gaming when it's kind of a kind of like over done. I guess like how do you like different?
She I guess from all the other channels cool nice. Thanks Doug
Just try
I
Don't want you to
Plug DJ in full plug DJ insole unfold goddamnit
Hey, man, how are you, good good? How are you guys we're great good?
All right my question is for for all of you. Um you're both collaborators with your significant others. What does that?
Experience like is it rough at times. What are the main points of having each other's presence when creating content a wonderful question
HS. No problem
You guys want to take that one I remember the Pokemon one
Lea was very hot it was really hot it's getting
frustrating
Come on go
Yeah, and it's like yeah, I'm doing all this stupid shit, but she's filming it yeah, so what's more uncomfortable
You know people give me the dirty looks like my throwing pokeballs at people and shit, she's like over there filming it
Yes, you guys are kindred spirit. You know what you're doing sunk heroes because you watch these documentaries about these guys climbing up to Everest
For iam shot with ducks we couldn't find any ducks
And then he ran into this lake
Going 4 in the morning it don't like get the mist down there you get the Ducks. That's when you got to get
the docks
So it's rough
When he asked like do his recording we like have our desks in our same computer room
So it's kind of weird if I'm like still in there like typing and linkies in my computer
So I like have to go down I go in like our basement and like wait till he's done recording
He has to you know. I'm getting his own, so
You have to work around yeah the delicate genius
I mean like I've never made videos without her
Yeah, I don't know how that's been yeah
You work together a lot more than we do I like for my channel. We do everything together like that
Then well were you making videos before you guys work together or for like how long were you already making videos?
I've been making them since I was like 12. Oh wow
new grounds oh
You're old school, dude
Damn, that's so cool
So in our case. We've been making videos since like day one so I've never even known a
Separate thing I mean it's always been like
Operation from the beginning like even coming up with the ideas and how to do
Even editing will still sit together, and I was like it was just funny, and she's like no
Do you ever be like
I mean sometimes. I would say like you should like put this in yeah
Take like an
Ending league oh, yeah
Yeah, I don't know I thought it was like a bad idea the way he was doing it
Like I didn't think he needed to make like the big like I don't know we always want to stay out of
Yeah, giant like the biggest company
Yeah, because like that was kind of his thing that built him up was the whole league thing. I was like well
You can just phase it out and not like do the huge
But it ended up being like a fine idea I mean
But did your feelings change over time now that you've seen the reaction
Yeah for sure yeah
He was right like but I'm like she knows more than me like what's good news channel, so
Sometimes Ethan will want to talk about something and we'll kind of stressed me out like you know I'm about to go on and call
the president
That was a joke
Cast a reference not an actual threaded no intention of hurting anybody, but sometimes. Yeah go back to my point
Yeah a lot of times
I would be like no we shouldn't and then he feels like we should and then
Eventually it was right you know so but it's important yeah
You know both sides you know because if I'm getting too gung-ho in my head. Yeah, it's like the you know the devil names
Yeah, I like just ringing it in. Yeah like think about it what you're doing yeah
yeah, I want to ask you about that League video I
love that hole I personally love the way you're just like fuck these guys I
Guess maybe just resonates with me because I'm a very much
Really identify with how they're just like
Just kicked your ass to the curb after you've promoted them for so long you know
Like you still think about that you stole. Are you upset at them?
It was a two week, ban
Like they banned him forever. Yeah, you were you had like a world might have been like a five day suspension
Okay, it was just the last straw though. Yeah, yeah
Yeah, they were really weird like
just that
Everyone talks about him. They said they like they have such a strict
you know
How they enforce it and it had been like building up for a while
And he had done like weird things with them in the past right like what though
You made some videos for them, and they like just didn't use it. That's what tell me about it
Well, it was actually a fun thing they did they were like they were gonna show one of my videos at the big tournament thing
hmm and
They had me make like five videos
Just like no that's not gonna work. That's not gonna
Like two or three weeks like now that's not gonna work, and they picked like the least offensive one. What did they expect?
Pretty cool
But did they did the other four ever get to see the light of day and put those up, okay good
yeah, at least that that's
So, I don't know, what do you think about right as a company? Are you just over it?
Yes, I don't really see people
Guys that did videos on it and like with it now yeah, it died out
Yeah, you were kind of a catalyst. I think the downfall of like the holy you tube. Did you kill League?
But seriously do you cuz I feel like League has waned a lot in popularity
I mean specifically from the moment when you're like. I'm not gonna play this game anymore. Yeah, that's what it feels like that's
Dead, I don't know if that's true, but it seems like it on YouTube
I still see it like on Twitch it has some of the highest numbers
but still I mean it's I think it's more like professional guys now I
like
Guys take it really seriously are really good
But it's funny, okay
I think you you just sensed that it was like timed it out like
You'd been doing it for like four years or something. Yeah, I think
Yeah, I mean you really
Like that collaboration, I do miss them like you know I'd bring and she would be playing all my friends
You know I try to include everybody in the video. It seems like nowadays just
To play all together with a group like that
Thanks. What was the one where you put me and John? It was a counter-strike one right? I was overwatch I was yeah
You're like you didn't even tell us you're recording
Did your play dota yeah
Yeah, what do you think oh that's impenetrable it's so hard to get into
I have like 2,000 hours clock, but just pretty much what you need to be like I kind of understand. That's like
Is there a what what competitive game are you playing these days overwatch?
Just still fun. Yeah, I think that's
Yeah, I haven't been playing as much
Just been really busy lately, but him especially he's been playing like every Mario game hmm just preparing for the new one
How are you feeling about the new Mario game? Dude, it's gonna be the best game ever made I
Love your faith in the the serious ancient
mythology of the Nintendo
Yeah, the whole man thing. I feel like us changing changing hands now. I feel like the Wii U was the trade-off between the old
Groove hmm no Zelda
Did I have like Zelda NV like I and I want to play it again for the first time. I love that game so much
Amazing how many hours you clocked playing that game
They don't want to show that to you, it's like we could see no
It's not though I'm just trying to do that goofy tricks for that video
You don't see me like you just see me doing it right I
Tried to do like 200 times just get the fucking balloon up there
Normally again with this balloon
So what's your favorite video that you've ever made?
Would you have a couple that sound out as like I am really proud of of how this came out
No he did a purge Oh what does that mean? I really do?
I just delete old ones just sucks now hmm his standards keep going up so I
Know jontron does that too and I was always like why are you doing this man? It has like three million views
Why are you killing this?
Do you delete videos with lots of views on it? Oh?
No not really I don't think just on private just like older ones that nobody's singing just unless them
So I went back and saw your oldest video was like
Battletoads 1
So that wasn't your first video
It's really good
Older channel-to-channel, what does it?
Mean face, I like phase dunkey, I want you to be in phase claim
I think they'll take him if not we'll start around. We'll call it face
This is this is Jason's official application to the face class you guys are watching. Please get back to us
So what what inspired you to make videos ah
I guess like back on Newgrounds you know mmm
Just see like all those goofy cartoons on the Internet Wow I want to do that make something like that
Of course that old shit you guys remember that new ground stuff, yeah
Edgar dance hell yeah all that stupid old shit
That's when we were kids and that was cool. That was amazing. It was the coolest and most amazing thing in the world
Yeah, I could you can make so you want it to be an animator originally. I guess so I was such a bad animators
He had some good ones he had like a series with Admiral Ackbar
Okay, and him and his friends was like voices. They were like 10 years
Yeah, that's what I was gonna actually do for my next video with comfort. I was gonna talk about all that stuff
so I'll wait I want to watch it through the lens I
Remember I would always be bugging like the guys like the popular guys from the time
They were so nice like they would just add you and tell you all the tricks and shit
I would just sit there and annoy him. I'm just like how did you do this? How did you do this?
Yeah
You guys remember
Legendary frog
he made uh I
Used to make like these green guys
He made all these old cartoons. They were so good
front page, right
Yeah
It was like the spray today or whatever. Oh, yeah. Yeah, yeah, what the um that was fun
Did you ever find success on new ground not only mmm-hmm kind of oh?
Yeah you do it like a collab with like ten different guys
And like every day. We'd put out a cartoon like ten of our little shorts. That's not your aunt you're an animator at heart
Worst is that relate to your name somehow the dunkey thing
Meatwad sprite which was my name and new girl
League that was my new girl's name hmm
This is bright like the little no video
Wait a sprite is like a little fairy. No. It's right and a video game. It's like you know like a picture of Mario
He's like doing this that's right, and if he like changes is saying. That's a different sprite. Okay, so that's like those old games
There'd be like eight sprites of Mario okay?
like the frames of him walk right
Yeah, god I could frame my animation so where did the name video game donkey come from I think I was talking about my friend
Dion he helped me get into you - big-time mm-hmm. I was just goofing off with him once
I told him the donkey or some
Told them yeah, and he we're playing left 4 dead and
He was stuck like at the beginning or something and I kept trapping them in
That's usually how it goes down with me and him playing
I'm just fucking we're winning the whole experience with him, right
And I said like to get out you had to say go go magic dunk
He would not say that
Eventually broke down
And and so the name was born
Can he help me give them to you -
Wow god bless him you throw him and then he was a sweet guy
Paper bat write a paper that gee yeah, I notice you're wearing some official merch
You guys got to sling some shirts man, I saw people saying I'm worse though
I hope I saw somebody say we were talking about this yesterday. You got a sling Murch
They're saying. I hope dunkey makes shirts someday
And and made by you right yeah, come on you guys how did I?
Well you can go to the website the link is at my Twitter
Which is VG, Lea B, but if you want to go directly? It's donkeys castle that looks
really cool
Yeah, it might take a couple weeks to ship with it
Head on over to dunky. Dunky castle you get some goddamn official Marsh. All right. I'm angry about it
But you have a like a comedic influence someone that you love that embodies the call me that you type that you love everybody
Everyone I talk to is a huge influence on all my stuff really
my friends family a
Lot of stolen jokes a lot of people you know friends
Like your joke you know some jokes you tell me off the cuff. Those are in their
Material, but there's not you ready to be the
Curator yeah, I'm the guy who maps it all together in a way. Yeah exactly. That's the talent
You're also fun. You're very time let's not
I'm funny, too
That's really cool though. Yeah, we crashed your website. Oh my god
Carnal nets can only have three people on there at a time starting a keel
Yeah
I could say every five minutes and IANS gonna make a queue you have to get in line to visit donkeys castle
Okay, check it tomorrow when?
We post this on youtube it's gonna be even crazier
Okay, well I'll do a restock and stuff when we get home. We gotta go back to Wisconsin. We're in California right now
I'm asleep though it'll be a week or two, but yeah
I love the homemade thing I used to get to use the grind for days. Yeah
Well, you know it's a personal
It's fun. It's fun
That's so wholesome. I think that's like honestly the most beautiful answer. I've ever heard and response to that
Do you like?
Do you have any professional comedians that you look up to or growing up? You're like this is the funniest guy want to be like
You know the dudes who write aquitine I love that when I was a kid yeah
It's so naturalistic like that's such a weird show Space Ghost mmm those guys are amazing
It's all Adult Swim right yeah, no Timoner
generic
I think a lot of youtubers really I guess yeah
I'm inspired by I think they just came around at like a perfect time like I remember the first time I saw them I was
In college by myself and in bedroom was like 3:00 a.m.. I was playing World of Warcraft, and it came on the TV
I was like I was like what is this at first? I was just like shocked just
Like oh my god, what this shit on TV, and then you come to love it cuz it's just
so weird and so
yeah, I remember what used to what my dad would put them Space Ghost down when I was a kid, I just
Had no comprehension. What was happening? It's like the most boring cartoon ever
Yeah, I guess a talk show with a guy. It's so boring for a kid yeah listen
I don't like this is the best thing
Do you ever would you do a show on Adult Swim?
Yes ready
I think we could put something together. What would it look like if you had your own show on Adult Swim
I'd be a cinematic masterpiece
Cinematic
What would you doing it I'd be you know
It'd be a science-fiction
No comedy at all
No dialogue
Would be about like gorillas
live-action girls yeah live-action gorillas, I'm like Futuristics
post-apocalyptic world
By the way, I hope nobody out there is gonna steal your idea
Don't swim has the budget fruit anything
With no words well, I listen if anybody from Adult Swim is watching we have got some fresh Bradbury's to pick here
so
That's really cool. See you
Where do you see yourself in five years? Do you see yourself making them like long-form content on somewhere else than YouTube or on YouTube
Are you pretty happy with the status quo? I think I guess I like this. I hope I can keep doing this for a while
He talks about a lot like if he could make a movie. He would make the best movie ever
I
Think that's more like a hobby type of do you write do you write screenplays and stuff?
He writes scripts for videos like mini movies so that is cool
I think you would make the best video. I'm just based on that some Nasus we offer the show
I don't think you could not make a comedy. I think you trying not to make a comedy would make it funnier
Yeah be like the room
Yeah, we've seen it I'm obsessed with it this one episode where
George is on a date, and he's like Jerry don't be funny
Am I being funny right now
So let's let's switch gears here, I want to talk to you about your dreams games critic video
Oh, did I say that right or did have a stroke game critics video games critics scream?
That's right. I have dyslexia so sometimes. I jumbled
jumbled my shit
Are you surprised by the reaction because people got generally you made a video well. Tell me about the what was the video about ah
Game critics they suck yeah
Yeah, you think we all been was feeling that
Look you going I you go on like Metacritic. Yeah, like you pointed out
but I tried that you know I tried to come down on the
Systemic you know issues just I'm like how the website you know makes you game critics do shit
Try to not come down on the people
you know
But karst all the funniest shit is them goofing up because the system is so shitty right like I Gina's like alright
You got two days to beat Zelda row and go review it
Yeah, fuck you need like three months to get through it again. You missed so big
Yeah, you give a real review
You showed that clip of jay-z which I thought was perfect where he was talking about music reviews
He's like people putting out album reviews, and one day. It's like you can't appreciate that album one day
Yeah, and a video games even crazier
Yeah, so long. There's so long
Short, but, so were you surprised by the amount of kickback you got from that cuz I saw a lot of critics
And he took a gazebo were just like who the fuck is this guy why the fuck should I care about a head?
Meanwhile that one was at the top of Reddit right everyone was talking about it, and they're just like oh
Who's this?
Fucking guy who does he think is like were you surprised by how they were just like I don't care about this guy at all
I mean all the people liked it
Yeah, I like the YouTube comments and stuff that was probably one of like the most agreeing with him
On like issues you know when he makes it more controversial one, but yeah
the critics themselves it was getting crazy on Twitter and
What was like the harshest thing somebody said about it I
Don't get dunkey on a high horse I
Don't understand putting a donkey on a high horse, that's fine get that donkey off the high horse
Like this shit sucks
Stupid yeah, they started ripping. I've never watched this and it sucks
Yeah, that like proved his point in itself like I didn't watch the whole video, but I know I just watch the video
But I gave it a 7 out of 10
Was there any reviewers who were cool about it we were like yeah you you have a point
There was a couple guys that you know try to actually talk about it mmm. I did come down
You know kind of hard on everyone even though. There are some good guys out there
Yeah doing good stuff you think that video had like any effect on the know
The point you made about like shitty awful video games getting 70s, it's so hero like I went and checked the
Mass Effect Andromeda already call it in dramatis, right
Like I got a seven
71 or 72 I Metacritic, and I just saw footage
I mean I never played the game, but I saw footage and her people thought I was like oh my god
What have they done that was like my favorite game of course? They'll done was that series?
Yeah, it's like it was born with a birth defect or something
beautiful
Yeah
this game in life came out like
very underway
But yeah, I think we all see that I think your criticism was much needed
As much my very important stuff there so are there critics that out there that you like particularly
YouTube guys I watch out of YouTube Hill game guys
I'm Pro Jared
He puts out some really good stunts his taste is just like the polar opposite of my interesting
So he's like he likes Final Fantasy, and it's like cool to see him explain
You know why he loves the old NES Final Fantasy, and it's like that's probably the last game
I would ever want to play hmm, and he makes it so you know do you play it after watching it?
sometimes
But it's awesome to see you know his viewpoint you know he illustrates it so good. Oh, that's cool. It's the wealth uh
It's a lot of good guys
Just a dude gaming historian
he'll like show you like old legal battles send video games I
Got Nintendo trying to like shut out black buster
Mm-hm you guys know about that. No tell me about that
Nintendo tried to make it so you couldn't rent their games from Blockbuster
I guess that yeah, they just thought renting is gonna cut down on the purchase price see no black mustard buys
Blockbuster buys a million billion copies yeah, but they
You know I never thought
How did renting work back in the day did Nintendo ever get a kickback from the rentals or a block to just buy that buys?
them and then read some no no they probably you know bought every copy and then paid an additional royalty to Nintendo probably I
Don't know it's with Nintendo. They're just like super protective of their IP like beyond
reasonable measure
It seems like across the board
So what are they getting crazier though like they're freaking Mario with that rabbit?
Love rabid peach
I was like who what is these there's this game Alan switch where it's like a turn base with Mario and right?
Know who the rabbit from rains from oh, it's pretty soft
Well there's a newer Rayman Origins no Rayman Raving Rabbids oh
There's like it was a TV show minigame kind of thing to have a minion vibe don't that they are a minion, okay?
I guess they came first. They didn't know the rabbits came first you minions sons of bitches
So wasn't what are they doing with their IP in that game you said they're getting worse oh, no. It's actually fun. Oh
So they're getting better no no maybe they did that way back to you know with a square Mario RPG
What makes a great critic in your mind
um
You know just well-spoken
Well-thought-out you have to understand you know what you like you have to understand. Why it appeals to you
You know I general like a lot of people
When I made that video some some critics like they'll message me and say yeah
I would do a review in the my editor wouldn't give this score
You know he would write through in the editor would say okay. Yeah this score. Oh, that's so crooked
What
so that explains why there's a disconnect between the score you gave me I saw this all the time or
In your video and in general it's like this video this game gave me literal cancer
So weird explain, so do you think that they do that simply because of some some deal with the publisher probably
You know so much like IGN
their whole
Their whole setup is you know they got to get ads, it's like a standalone website
It's not in YouTube right so they got to get their own ads
So they can't piss off the people you know who puts the ads on IGN game maker
Yeah, so can't drive you can't fuck around with them. Oh
That's such a rough model
Yeah III know that youtubers like tech youtubers get in the same trouble
Like they get a lot of shit like what kind of tech like phone reviewers. Oh people like that or a lot, or you know
like they'll get invited to
Preview a phone before the general public sure and they're like
If I give it a bad a review are they gonna revoke my access maybe
Yeah with that then you just have to hope that the audience like recognizes
That's what's going on and you can like pick and choose, which you know critics you listen to or like how to?
Receive the you know the score like what it actually means like a 70 is like. It was really bad on
The website 7 is good good 713, that's the worst game
This is the top question from the subreddit, so I have to ask you
Fuck marry or kill Donkey Kong Country Super Mario Brothers 2 and knack
Do you even know what that game is I don't think he's ever done one of those
Oh, yeah, you know what you have to choose one of the three you have to choose
Which one you want to fuck which one you want to marry and which one you want to kill
Donkey Kong Country Super Mario Brothers 2 and Mac
Isn't the game or the character I think they MEA well, that's a fun follow-up
Disc yeah, do you want yeah?
Okay that even legal
Say the characters then alright, I guess they have to have sex with
The human with the game yeah the game Mario
What do you even do with that Love Finds away yeah like that guy with his cars
If you need to reach something so that means you would kill Mario
I appreciate you taking that relatively seriously, so we're we're marrying that we're killing a Mario and we're fucking Donkey Kong I
Love it. Okay. I'm glad yeah, that was
You're a fan of hip hop right I've noticed you like referencing hip. Hop. Do you let him up? Yeah?
That's some some of your hip hop head
Sometimes he's a rapper
He really does I'm Bandcamp you have a full album. Uh-huh just like recycled YouTube songs
That he some rap songs from YouTube like just videos
You know where can we find that people deserve to hear that it's on Bandcamp. Donkeys album Jason's
Pretty much, just Kendrick. I love Kendrick. Yeah, it's the busker
What's your favorite album with his I?
Don't know good kid maad city damn your boys yeah, that's dope that's probably that's the most cohesive story, I think
That one has the most bangers mm-hmm, and it sounds like the you know a normal. That's when I first heard
I was like this is just normal. This is this terrible message
You know like if some more if somebody else if my mom heard it
Yeah, but if you actually listen. It's like you know a really positive message
It's like the whole right 180 of what rap is yeah? I love that. I love Kendrick. I really like hip-hop
It's like musical and his stuff is very jazzy and musical
And I cried and Mike I mean he's just on top of his game his lyrics aren't music
How'd you like his new album the damn? Uh? I was really good cool. He has some really good tracks on there
Oh, yeah, what was your favorite one?
Last one, Duckworth Oh, Duckworth yeah, it's crazy time twister yeah three different beats
It's the craziest shit ever
Do you like that's it always has to listen to whatever? I hear of that kind of stuff is like his mix that he makes
So he like he edits the songs too alright. Don't you like take that part seriously? He edits them like really deeply
And he makes like mix CDs in our car our car. I was like a hundred CDs
What he's editing and made yeah, so there's a song and there's a particular part
You don't like you'll edit it out and make your own dad director's cut yeah
Even with like Beatles songs I was like what did you do this?
Choruses I always edit the corner sound because this is repetitive
You're just like no you guys
I want that I want Jason's director's cut and all these popular albums
I think yeah, I didn't you like distribute it to at least one of my friends
So when you make the cut, would you make sure it sounds sure yeah, yeah with Adobe you can it's written
It's easy man a lot more songs unless there's like no jazz
Some songs you just can't ever do it with it cuz there's so much stuff in the background
But a lot of songs are just so simple. It's just like
You will never know people who have never heard the song we'd just be like oh, thanks. That's real. They're like oh wow
There's no course. That's how they make it in the fucking studio. They just clip it right there. Definitely. I've seen him do it. Yeah
So you can just
To say but to say the chorus once and
Loop that right. You know rarely ever a guy will just actually sing it himself. So you just loop their ass right back out
That's harder, though with like real. Good guys like Prince
He would like you know he would sing the chorus every time so it's like different a little every time
We have a good prince mix CD in your favourite band sound like you're pretty big into music
He's the best man wait, I'm not Frank Ocean sea pups Frank Ocean is good too. Oh Frank Ocean
You ever listen to Tyler the Creator Frank Ocean did a cool yeah?
I think you'd like it a lot. It's great flower boy. I bought his sneakers
I like the blue sneakers it has a B on the back
Yeah, I love yeah, I think that you don't have to like
Be a fan of something to like it like aesthetically yeah
Liner he's a yeah
He's an expert shoe maker in my opinion. Yeah, well
You know what meaning? You'll always say our dream when she drops teddy fresh coming in about a week, yeah
That's if we ever see someone on the street wearing like a Teddy fresh piece of clothing
And they don't know who we are don't know
I think you can definitely get there with that that was good. Thank you didn't appreciate that
Do you guys ever
Follow like big drama on YouTube like the leafy keemstar
Idubbbz rice gum whatever crap like do do you love that or you just don't care?
Like look at it and be like haha
He's so out of the loop
I will have to like inform him of some things if like I don't know if it's like sort of related to him at all
But he will never like look at it himself
That is sometimes
Some stuff. That's it if it's like popped up at him yeah. He doesn't like seek it out or anything
I still don't watch jontron because he's black
Video was so crazy and again. Oh my god. I love you still see that comment Oliver
He just finds a good way to like call stuff out that he sees in him
He just drops it and moves on I got a question for you
Rest in peace Robin Williams
Or both
Good all right
He's choking up Matt Damon, she's a good
Well I suspect that part of this is
like satirical about how people
Overestimate the impact of people's death who they'd ever met well. It's you know
Don't really want to praise it it's something you would see on YouTube too like some kid would make it
That's definitely in the vein of that
Kid would make you know that's what they would make their tribute to Ram Williams right just be the worst shit ever
I think you would like to okay. Yeah, I think Robin would like that too. I was touched by it
especially when you zoomed in undead
What do you make videos like this or like one that pops out - my - space safari
Loved it I learned it. I like this is that like a troll on fans. Are you genuinely just like this is good
I just wanted to have a relaxing space Safari like something weird just surprise your audience god bless
Ya, he was into it
I remember when he was making it you
Took like a week or so and you were like just editing the heck out of it
You're like ya gotta get the perfect clip for this song. Where did you find all that footage because you had some incredible
Yeah, a lot of my videos are I just like cycled through all these other YouTube stuff
This is like probably three hundred thousand other videos and Sally's video
That's sometimes. They get mad. Do you when you when you what when you use other people's footage?
Yeah, I tried to credit people, but there's like you know there's some money hmm
but if they ever contact now definitely
Credit them, and I try to credit ones that I use a lot hmm
Do you care about your like? I know that some people are not gonna get this like the space safari one
And they're probably gonna get like butter
But do you you're just like
You don't care and you're make. Do you feel like you're making it for yourself, or do you how much do people?
Oh yeah, I guess sometimes you gotta make you know something new
That they won't expect sometimes you got to play you know tell what they want give the fans exactly what?
Sometimes you gotta give them really well. You got to give them what they want, but they don't know they want
That's the trick that's true that is the trick they probably didn't want that
I was just like man. This guy is the shit he'll just he doesn't give a fuck I
Did like the video. I'm not sayin um
What do you think lately I've been having a hard time
enjoying video games
I cannot find a video game that I like playing since Zelda and before that I couldn't find one is it me
Or is it the state of gaming like do you what do you think about the state of gaming? Uh-huh I think it's
Worse than ever you know the worst shit is coming out and the best stuff is coming out mm-hmm
Maybe just gotta you know branch out try different stuff that you wouldn't play normally. How do you find the good stuff?
How do you sort it? Ah?
Yes, I'm gonna cook. Oh that helps
That's all right
You just try everything yeah, yeah play a lot of stuff, I'm gonna have to just hit you up on the weekly
I'll do have like a weekly update for the show Ducky's recommended game
I
Often look at the user reviews I find like that's a badge almost a better indication than the actual Metacritic score
Sometimes yeah, you can get a feel
But everyone's taste is so different like me and him my taste is really different
Like he'll get he has a short like patience for games
So if anything is like you know like old NES games
You can't like stick to it to like beat any of those games just mononymously idea
Memorizing. Yeah, if you read the wrong review it might be the complete opposite of what your opinion would be so
Just try it anyway. Do you ever read reviews, or do you just look at the score?
Yeah I read a ton
nice
Damn you're the real deal
Shit dude
I don't know just...
What games have you tried? Do you like those kind of?
Games where you just kind of guides you around like journey
Have you ever played that I loved that game about journey journey was the game you're laughing at me you hated it, right?
I love Journey
Okay
He love it, I don't like it at all
Loved it it was like a magical journey if you will
Ah Journey, yeah we played it together - I liked it too
It was really stunning, It was relaxing intuitive, I felt like I was on an adventure I loved it
There's some Abzu
From the art director a journey looks like a fish, Oh what for what console, I think that's for everything switch
Inside did you guys try out no. I'm write these down as
I'm actually gonna write dan. Just sent you know. He said inside is so fucking good
Thanks for the feedback, thanks for the light feed back inside and gazook see
You
You guys out there. Take it from me up from from dunk. I was a really short one say yeah
It's really easy to get into is there any good games on switch cuz I'm like I played Zelda sure loved it
What's some great ones that I need to get on switch? Uh-huh I thought that Mario rabbits on this one
Yeah, I played that a bit. That's pretty fun. Did you beat it almost okay?
The snipper clips game you might like playing it together. There's like this one, and you have to like snipper clip. It's really cute
Yeah, it's like these little paper like shapes
And you have to work together to like do whatever it wants you to basically think I sorry
We haven't can yeah, I try that 100 right now this down sip I see people saying stardew valley Oh
I couldn't I was like it's not for everyone. I loved it so much personally, but I planted a couple turnips
Games like that you have to self-direct
Like you have to set a goal for yourself like I love doing stuff like that like I was even into Minecraft like a lot
Because I like to like just decide like I want to build like this
And then you're just working towards your own goal like he can't do that at all. He wants it all to me like
Telling him what to do. I guess. I like that yeah
Well, we need to worry. We're the carry yeah, you like started Valley too, but in a different way you didn't play
This much stuff I just I played it for a couple hours, I did really like how it's like
Oh build a farm, but then all this cool other shit is happening. There's a little Indian the storyline
Was it really one dude
And concerned eight
Concerned at least you guys
Yeah
So what big games? Are you looking forward to in this coming?
Years ahead you're ahead Mario
I'm excited for stardew valley multiplayer to finally come out. Oh, yeah, they've been like working on it for a long time
Together you can destroy each other's farms
That's pretty much all that was gonna happen
Farmville yeah, I'm probably gonna set if you didn't watch it's gonna be bad
yeah, that's what happened when we played Minecraft together you just
ruined up the house
Can you not it's too tempting?
So what are the chances of Mario being bad? I mean let's be real
Listen I want to spread here zero zero percent everyone zero it might not be
You know there's a small percent. It won't be the best destined thing with Mario
It's either the best game of all time rs is mediocre
Even if it's the best shit ever because it has to come Mario's this every Mario's like the best shit ever
That's so cool. Yeah. It's kind of like this old saying about
pizza
They says or well. He says like pizza is like
sex
When it's good, it's great and when it's bad. It's still pretty good
So Mario
So oh let's take some calls getting towards the end of this year we got
Squiggle d-doc. Let's move it in a squiggle of that. Talk to me. Oh hey
McKenna you're sorry
With your experience of VR. Do you guys think VR will become a gaming standard in the future
Or is it just a fad hmm cool nice question hmm also Ethan if you have a chance to try out had in time
had in time
Mario yeah, it's very inspiring okay cool. I'll check that out. Thanks. Buddy another indicator hm
Do you think VR is a passing fad? Oh?
China
In the current state yeah in the current version. They don't go away. Yeah, but eventually you know once it's sold like right now
It's like it's bulky and
Wires go on in like a hundred under this computer. It's like a 50-pound thing on your head, and it makes you all sweaty
It's impressive though oh yeah
Something you want to see it, and then you're like okay where am I gonna store all of this stuff?
I do that for like an hour yeah
I need a really powerful machine - yeah and running on that's how I feel about the vibe. Yeah like one super impressive. Yeah
Once they like the hardware is like
Yeah, if they just like get it refined and you know it's hard to imagine what they'll come up with but I mean
It's possible you're getting there. Yeah
Indeed the actual immersive experience you get from like the vibe is
Incredible I think once they get those real games out there
Yeah right now. It's just mostly demos yeah, I just didn't know still the
Valves the lab is the best game on the art, which is just a demo
Let's bring it in from
You oh, I moved him in the wrong room
Sorry, I did it probably had a great question. Oh there is the best
The best go hey, hey, what's up? How you doing?
Pretty good so my question was it's a little bit freaky yet
so what was your favorite console like going all the way back from the first ones to the current generation and
What was your favorite game for that console?
Ku ku, thanks, dude
You ready for that
Uh, I guess the Nintendo 64 mmm
All right doesn't get better than that Mario 64 banjo-kazooie uh
Diddy Kong Racing a lot of good games I
Think your favorite is my sixth super out of yeah - 64 is my favorite game of all time
So I guess I got to pick down that game was shocking when I came out yeah
It was like what I remember when I was a kid, and I saw it in the store. I was like
That was the big that I think that was a bigger leap than VR really
Huh 2d to 3d was just like what the shit yeah, you're right
So it was that the best console the best time in gaming ever the Nintendo 64
and then you on the other side you had the PlayStation which was an awesome I
Don't know there's still I feel like it's better now than ever no that's nice. You've seen one area
You can play all that sit now. I'm still out there
That's true. I guess nobody's making
You love it. I honestly don't have strong opinion about it. I was always a PC gamer the deepest
Video game whole crack whole meme hole I've ever been in was EverQuest
Yeah, I was a piece I've always been a PC gamer, but I you know I always played all those consoles, but I never really
Never pride me away from ever crack
Because you all played World of Warcraft, and you're like oh yeah, but let me tell you
I tried that game
Yep yeah, that's that's a free game you gotta do oh, yeah, you still play ten years
I
Don't play it like you know all the time like I would then but I liked
Usually for some reason in the winter because I mean we're in, Wisconsin
We're locked in yeah
Like for the nostalgia and just for something to do, but yeah, it seems like a really cool game. I mean for some people
Some people just think it's like a laughing stock
But I was always like a 2d MMO just the idea of it, it's pretty what we're doing yeah, I love the graphics
I love like dressing up your character and on that you say, I don't know it's a more like girly one
I guess I tried to do like wow and other ones
But just couldn't do it know if she doesn't like the grant if she doesn't think the game is cute. She won't play
I have to be looking at it
I agree it's like offending
Never really cared about graphics. I just care about
having a good time I
Got into one game in my life really nice jumper
Tetris that but I was gonna say bagel
That's the game that comes
Yeah, really. I think we've got scammed into buying it
We bought tackle tackle nights, and that was when we were in Santa Cruz
We were dead broke and all we had was an Xbox and peggle and we like full completed that
Let me ask you guys this we're we're coming here towards the end
What are five games that everybody should play or not?
Maybe not five but likes the games that come to mind really you like games you have to play this
Let's go back and forth
Yeah play that no way I was gonna say Myra sunshine I've never played that I see this shot
Let me buy it on switch what how do I play it?
You can't play any Mario. They gotta bring all that old stuff on this one. That's what I'm saying
It's so I am the Wii right no
Dusty box yeah
Yeah, you like Mario Galaxy I did like a that was nice
What else all right Mario Galaxy
No, I would say though it started to Valley, too
and also
Animal Crossing new leaf
That's when I got really into to I have like three game cartridges for it
Pop them out, I'd like used to Game Boys at once
Once yeah, I took his reminds me of their my EverQuest days
They called multi boxing is that what it's come on set up two pcs and I can have someone Auto
Healing you you were multi box. I was for animal crossing money
You stole mine, she took my animal crossing cartridges to put more hair stuff on it
she's like deleted my
She got so mad my guy from Animal Crossing like
Don't come in right. You don't even get the pic
villager moves into your city
And she could not get rid of it would always stay there no matter what?
Two months
Ruined my town cuz his house was a big trash can and that was your guy
Yeah, you came from I came from his village in the mine. You brought the virus. He didn't with you
Alright well
Let's wrap it up as we do with with many of our guests. We asked. Do you guys have any ghost stories?
paranormal
encounters
Yes, we do you do do you have?
No spooky alert I have like two, but okay
They're not I wouldn't say they're like ghosts. Just likes paranormal kind of stuff
Okay, so the first one it is like just
Kind of more personal to me. I don't know if it's like evidence of any sort of paranormal stuff, but yeah
So basically when I was about
11 or 12 I think I was in bed, and I was like about to fall asleep
And I was laying with my back to the wall
So like I was facing the edge of the bed that was like out to the room
you know so I like open my eyes for some reason and right like right in front of my face like two inches away I
saw like a big statue guy I
Would describe it like kind of a Tiki head, but like also kind of like Easter Island heads if you know those statues
My knee is just like staring at me, and I was like so scared
I just like froze and then he just said I'll be back
Blanket
Yeah, I was just like frozen until I fell asleep. I guess, but yeah
Just one time yeah
And that's the thing so for me. I like having in my head like I don't share my brain like conjured it up
But it could do it again, so I could see him again
He's a liar he'll be back. He might still be back. They were taunting me. It's like a ghost for me, so
Not like that intense
Sometimes, I'll wake up from dreaming, and it's like your dream
Juice is left over in your brain, and you can like hallucinate. Yes, if you were still dreaming
I'm sure it was something like that you got dream juste yeah
But it could happen does it feel like it was paranormal deal like it did at the time
I was like I know I saw it like I told my parents and everything I was like I know he was there like I
saw this guy
It was like it was like a stone statue
But yeah, no, I know it was just like you know I'm sleeping or whatever but
Cuz my brain like I made it up. I could just do it again, so yeah, yeah
Well I I don't know
I'm just a dream juice god damn it
You take yes. Yeah, no I have yeah there you go. What are your ghosts?
Alright, so he'll protect you. He'll be fine. Okay. I just didn't know if yeah
Yeah, well my other one is more like aliens, I guess
Yeah, okay, so this one was more recent
It was when I was like going to school in Arizona College, and I was like flying home
For winter break or something and I was just getting up
And we really got the full height you know for the the rest of the flight
You know we were way up and I saw I looked out the window and there was like this black
It was like a blimp. I feel like but it was really shiny kind of like a Zeppelin
But it didn't have wings. It was just kind of like coasting along, and it was going faster than our airplane
It was moving like kind of in the same direction as us like a slightly different angle
But it was going faster than the plane. I was like what is that like blimp going so fast, but it was nighttime
What shape it was daytime?
Sun was like really shiny on it, yeah
so that
Yeah, but I'm like you know like the logical part of me is like well if they're flying airplane
They know everything like what's flying up here with them
Yeah, like it can't be anything like too crazy, but I know that was really fast
Stuff like that yeah, I don't know what and and Jason alien encounters
I saw I was mainly to ask this before we end it because you guys have just got engaged and it's wonderful
It's adorable. I love it and I was wondering how did you guys meet? Yeah? Oh?
Kind of an interesting story yes the short version is that like I knew him from his videos
I was like a fan of his videos
Yeah the rest of it is like a little bit, creepy like we were both kind of crazy
Not like but ya know I saw one of his videos, and he was like at the Museum
So it was like Night at the Museum or something, and it was really funny video
But I noticed that it was a museum that I had been to so I was like this guy lives
It great by me like I'm gonna really
I'm in Wisconsin - I just added him on skype now. This is the part where he was creepy no
I just typed his name in
Yeah, I added like there was only two that came up, so I was just like and friend add friend, yeah
He accepted because he would go through and look for girls
You know it's not that
Work dolly like yeah, that's kind of like a recipe for something like that wouldn't work
I I know what you probably added like a thousand girls are
Yeah, we played games together online for a while before we met in person yeah, we just started hanging out
I think that's cool. I think that's a wonderful beautiful tale of love triumphing against odds and
also insights memories of was Robin Williams and
Guys it was a joy as a player privilege and an honor to have you guys thanks for coming
With us
So guys, thanks for watching I hope you had fun and enjoyed it
I'm gonna put up the thread for questions for next week for a Crip Aryan
That's it. That's all she wrote for this week
So thank you guys for watching and appreciate Jason is turning and facing the wall Lee is following suit
Can we get off shot and these?
know
basically
Dan our producer was like listen when they're not talking directly towards you you need to face the wall
Because it's awkward for them, and we don't like people to look them in the eyes
So they're they're great guests. They're the best guess
Anyway guys. Love you all yeah, and have a great week
Thanks. I saw it Europeans getting triggered that I says. Thanks for spending your day with us
Thank you for spending your day with us Americans those of you in Europe. You're spending your evening with us
He means sorry late night. Whatever time of day. It is. Thank you goddamnit super early morning. Thank you everybody out there
Anyway guys. See you next week Tata